la justice tourangelle se penche donc
sur le cas d'un potentiel prédateur
sexuel à faire sensible car cette fois
c'est un sapeur-pompier professionnel
l'homme d'une quarantaine d'années
soupçonné d'avoir à budget abusé pardon
de jeunes sapeurs-pompiers trois
adolescents qui étaient en formation
devant le palais de justice de Tours les
explications de Romain Delville à ce
jour trois plaintes pour viol agression
sexuelle et corruption de mineurs vise
un sapeur-pompier professionnel de
Touraine des faits qu'il aurait commis
sur trois JSP des jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers
âgés entre 16 et 17 ans l'homme
aujourd'hui
âgé d'une quarantaine d'années et
lui-même passé par une section des JSP
avant d'être pompier volontaire puis
pompier professionnel sous-officier et
formateur le premier signalement a lieu
début novembre par les parents d'un
jeune à l'issue d'un stage au centre de
formation du service départemental
d'incendie et de secours à Ballan-Miré
très vite en interne la hiérarchie
décide de suspendre à titre
conservatoire le quadragénaire de ces
fonctions de pompiers volontaires lui
qui est depuis en arrêt maladie dans ses
fonctions professionnelles contactez le
10 fait le choix de l'établir aucune
communication sur le sujet ni
l'état-major ni la présidente du conseil
d'administration la conseillère
départementale Jocelyne Cochin suite à
cette première plainte auprès de la
brigade des mineurs la police interpelle
l'individu le 17 novembre selon nos
confrères de la Nouvelle République des
échanges à connotation sexuelle des
photos de pénis aussi sont découvertes
dans le téléphone portable l'homme est
aujourd'hui soupçonné d'avoir imposé des
fellations des masturbations et des
relations sexuelles à des mineurs tous
JSP l'enquête est en cours d'instruction
pour déterminer les faits et l'ampleur
des faits notamment le nombre des
victimes